TONIGHT.
>> Colby: THEY'RE GOING TO SEE
A CAROLINA TEAM THAT'S BEEN
ROLLING, AND A TOUGH ONE
AGAINS EIGHT -0 RECORD TO THE
TEST.
GET CALLED.
IT WAS SEBASTIAN AHO GOT AWAY
WITH ONE THERE AND THAT
SHOULD'VE BEEN A FIVE ON THREE
FOR THE ES INTO THE SLOT,
CREATING A LOT OF CONFUSION
AMONGST THE BLACKHAWKS DEFENSE.
FANS ON
COUNTING.
I WAS LOOKING GOT A SIXTH IN TH
THAT'S TOO MANY, CHRIS.
>> Chris: ONE TOO MANY, IN BUT
PAN HAS BEEN A
PUCK TO THE NET.
THAT STICK OUT
IT A LITTLE BIT, THEY CALLED IF.
HE'S FALLING.
HE HAS THE PRESENCE OF MIND TO
DISH THE PUCK BACK T TO  PROTEC
ICE.
CAROLINA WILL COME AT  ONE.
>> Chris: THE PUCK QUICKLY IS
LIFTED UP ALONG THE GLASS BYE B
DACH.
STILL 1:22 TO GO ON THE POWER  Y
TOWARDPAYING
OFF FOCAROLINA HURRICANETHE
CIRCLE.
BACK TO THE POINT, BEAR,DOING
WHAT THEY DEFENSIVELY.
THIS POWER PLAY, THIS IS
IMPORTANT TOGLASS.
>> Colby: HERE'S THE LAST
CHANCE FOR PATRI WALL AND FLIPP
DOWN BY TROCHECK.
WATCH  THIS LITTLE MOVIE MAKES.
YOU CAN SEE HIS SKATES GOING
LATERAL ON THE BLUE LINETHIS
POWER PLAY THAN THE EASE.
>> Colby: CAROLINA CAN TAKE AS
MANY FREE LOOKS FOR THE NEXT 50
SECONDS FOR THAT OPE EACE FOR KE